avant les jeunes ne portait pas trop de
sa vie parce que les jeunes de venir si
jeunes et ils salissent et on peut pas à
la moindre seulement s'étaient tous les
grands mamans ou les mamans et les
filles qui s'étaient mariés mais
maintenant avec le ton le sa vie aussi
ça change et ce n'est jamais moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qichen qui veut plus fort c'est le pari
parce que c'est un peu un combo combes
riom ça leur prend beaucoup de temps
donc c'est pas pratique la jeunesse qui
revente 20 20 ans 30 ans 35 ans elle
elle a envie de porter des jeans des
t-shirts des vêtements près du corps la
mode qu'on retrouve partout en europe
dans tous les magazines ce qui porte
préjudice à mon avis à tous les petits
seront visés trouve par exemple du côté
de l'arrêt parce que ces gens là n'ont
plus le même potentiel pour créer sa
rythme mais il ya un nouveau gérer une
nouvelle direction qui est prise par le
fait qu' on veut continuer à développer
et des régions qui n'arrivent plus à
trouver de marché donc on veut essayer
de donner de nouveaux produits a créé de
manière à continuer à travailler et à
utiliser ces matières premières qui sont
fabuleuses et vraiment il n'a une
posture
une habile très très ponctuel très frais
homme élégant et à vraiment magnifique
on voit que de plus en plus les filles
veulent porter des saris non seulement
ford et des mariages ou des phares et
très importance ou de fort des occasions
mais pour tous les jours ça riquelme et
marion achille magma d'auvergne ou iron
man the wedding
[Musique]
monaco 9e a déjà aidé à l'origine ces
jobs à vos petits mots si tous les bons
leviers majeurs français qui naîtra en
tant que si je fais mes efforts que de
vraiment trouver des moyens de son style
de trouver les formes conclure il forte
et très fascinant et d'être réglée en un
come-back dzeko en trouver du design en
même temps très ouvert et demi en
goguette sexy av
technique en choc pdci twilight et
devait entre sex friends une seconde
édition un style messari avec des
baisses avec des t-shirts avec des
chemises et de le porter avec des
pantalons avec les filles n'avaient qu'à
des habits sur les jours aussi le
expérimenté jean costa elle est blonde
et sentheim de blasons corps top 10
octobre les réformes et ce match sur
deux mais ce match ne ressort texte fort
mais ce match offre comme il est il
possible pour l'heure c'est à nous de
leur faire croire qu on peut le porter
sont les différentes parties